bei uns wurde nicht der op-termin von
unserer seite abgesagt sondern meine
tochter hat ein loch oder hatte ein loch
in der scheidewand und die op wurde dann
seitens des deutschen herzzentrums
mehrfach abgesagt mit bezugnahme auf die
korona maßnahmen um im notfall die
entsprechenden kapazitäten vorzuhalten
leider muss ich ja auch berichten dass
meine op in der klinik abgesagt wurde
weil die betten für bewohner patienten
frei gehalten werden sollten bzw das
personal dringend benötigt wurde ich
habe zwar mittlerweile einen
ersatztermin aber auch der steht bis
jetzt nicht unter einen sehr guten stern
weil die kliniken rund um münchen
sehr voll sind und es kann mir wieder
passieren dass abgesagt werden muss die
heute an zwei gerichten prüfen brauche
jetzt auch das soll nun so muss ich ins
hofer das ist irgendwann anfang nächsten
jahres spazieren
meine wurde auch abgesagt wenn corona
bzw schon dreimal
ich habe ständig schmerzen am knie wenn
ich jetzt so spazieren gehe durch corona
bin ich auch schon arbeitssuchend
geworden weil corona weg ist kann ich
keine arbeit finden wo ich tätig werden
kann wo ich das nie belasten muss von
der bild-zeitung und zwar habe ich eine
frage ob ischen ein fall gab wo ein
patient abgelehnt werden musste für ein
intensiv bett
frage ist jetzt wie definieren sie
abgelehnt ob es schon situationen
gegeben hat wo ein patient dann etwa
verlegt worden ist von einer klinik zu
einer anderen weil die klinik eben an
die grenze dessen kommt was geht das hat
es schon gegeben das hat es auch im
frühjahr im frühjahr schon gegeben und
ansonsten gibt es natürlich konzept
regional die gibt es aber auch jenseits
der pandemie weil den umstand dass eine
intensivstation voll ist wenn man es so
sagen will also nicht zusätzlich
patienten aufnehmen kann den hat es ja
auch schon vor
corona gegeben und dann wird würde eben
etwa im notfall ein entsprechender
rettungswagen dann umgeleitet werden in
ein anderes krankenhaus das hat es
vorher gegeben das wird es mit
sicherheit auch während corona geben und
ich denke auch nach colón mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bate schau dich hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren